voici Paul Verlin et son avocat ami et
bienfaiteur Marcelle Julian alors je
vais vous poser la question que je vais
poser à tous les personnages en cher et
en Haos qui vont parler des personnages
de cire comment va Paul Verlin bien
c'est la première fois qu'on lui pose
cette question depuis qu'il est mort
mais il a l'air d'aller bien sauf qu'il
a m'a changé deux choses très graves la
première c'est qu'il veut savoir si
François est là vous me le direz parce
que sinon franis ah ça ça vaamener ce
qui veut pas surtout c'est qui est Jules
est-ce que Jules est là alors Jules
goncour non non vous allez voir il m'a
dit que si Jul il partait je crois que
ça vous incommoderait tous don Jul Jul a
dit de luiroyable Berl il a dit diogen S
il a dit que c'était un chien c'était
une Yenne et c'était Jules Renard donc
cétait quand mmeou ah non mais Jul
renard n'est pas là donc ça va on peut
rester ça va très bien quant à au rest
c'est un scoop qu'il m'a autorisé à vous
dire on a on sait qu'il est mort en
prononçant un mot exactement un prénom
qui était François alors les mauvaises
langues elles sont nombreuses on dit bon
après Arthur voilà qui un François il y
en a eu d'autres et que c'était un
François qui avait été débauché par le
pauvre Verlin à qui on a dit faux faux
il garantit non alors on dit c'est
peut-être aussi qu'il avait l'habitude
de de faire des fessis sur lui-même
alors il s'appelait volontiers
Saint-Antoine de pas dou parce qu'il
était souvent violent il il disait
souvent aussi qu'il était Saint-
François de sad et ça n'a rien à voir
avec tout cela l'homme qu'il admirait
plus que tout au monde un énorme poète
un poète qui l'avait précédé François on
peut deviner alors voilà
et il avait fait il y a deux ver qui le
prouve il avait dit j'idolâtre François
viillon mais être lui comment se fait et
bien voilà pourquoi il est mort en
disant le nom de François billon il
tenait que ça soit mais on ne trouve pas
ça dans les biographies de verl non il
était temps qu'on corrige aujour'hui et
il a une dernière vœ c'est qu'il
s'attendait à ce qu'il y ait un autre
écrivain vivant celui-là oui qui été là
pour boire l'absinte avec lui ce soir et
qui lui ressemble un peu en ce moment et
qu'on adore tous c'est Antoine Blondin
alors il recr il est content de ouais ça
il regrette l'absence de de rimbaau et
et rimbaau moins il a eu des BR oui
pensis qu' il aurait préféré aujourd'hui
euh Antoine blond anine qui le emmené
alors si Antoine est quelque part
merveilleux je lui ramène très bien
merci alors merci Verlin merci Marcel
Julian et